les élections en union soviétique un
sérieux avertissement pour le parti et
pour le pouvoir leur candidat parfois en
difficulté l'état d'urgence en alaska la
marée noire est immense une polémique a
éclaté à propos de la responsabilité de
la compagnie exode
en corse après l'échec des négociations
la riposte des syndicats ceux du sud et
ceux du nord ils étaient réunis en fin
d'après-midi les argentins à
aubervilliers et et le retour du groupe
c il joue famille d'artistes au théâtre
de la commune
bonsoir un vrai casse tête pour mikhaël
gorbatchev les élections ne clarifie pas
la situation d' union soviétique
elles ont plutôt tendance à l'obscurcir
les résultats définitifs ne seront
connus que dans une dizaine de jours
mais tout de même
le pouvoir est sérieusement secoué
exemple l'élection à moscou de boris
eltsine
près de 90% des voix une vraie claque
pour le candidat du parti autre exemple
les élections des nationalistes dans
certaines républiques tout de suite
analyse du scrutin georges bortoli à
moscou dans le cadre solennel du soviet
municipal de moscou du conseil municipal
de moscou si vous préférez vient d'être
proclamé les résultats des élections
pour la capitale des résultats
impressionnants puisque boris eltsine
obtient plus de 89% des suffrages
exprimés suffrages eux mêmes très
nombreux puisque la participation
électorale et de +2 83% la capitale a
donc littéralement plébiscité monsieur
biais de la publicité parce que cet
homme le choix surtout aux apparatchiks
pour parler aux gens de leurs problèmes
soulevés ravitaillement appartements
exigus ou introuvables hôpitaux délabré
yalcin s'adresse aux mécontents voilà
pourquoi il a gagné contre le candidat
de la puissante organisation du parti
pour moscou et s'il n'y avait encore
connu mais c'est l'exemple est aussi
suivi par la deuxième ville du pays
leningrad ou le premier secrétaire du
parti la plus haute personnalité locale
donc est également battue mais le plus
grave se situe sans doute dans les
régions de travail les problèmes
nationaux par exemple à erevan toujours
en état de siège
les arméniens ne cache pas que pour eux
les élections de dimanche ne sont qu'une
répétition générale d'autres élections
qui se dérouleront en novembre et qui
désigneront les nouvelles assemblées
locales celles qui se prononceront sur
les brûlant problèmes d'autonomie qu'on
arménie comme dans les pays baltes et
d'ailleurs
l'automne prochain risque d'être chaud
et en effet j'ajoute que dans certaines
républiques par exemple les républiques
baltes
les représentants nationaliste arrive
souvent en tête exemple en lituanie ils
sont en tête dans 31 des 39 districts
électoraux
autre exemple en ukraine cette fois les
électeurs ont carrément rayer les noms
le nom du seul candidat qui se
présentaient à kiev le candidat du parti
très conservateur il n'a donc même pas
été deux exemples qui montrent que les
citoyens soviétiques rejettent souvent
l'appareil le pouvoir le parti gilles
rabin l'un de nos envoyés spéciaux à
moscou en a rencontré de ses citoyens
portrait de l'un d'entre eux volodia est
ouvrier spécialisé et membre du parti
communiste
il a 40 ans il travaille depuis 18 ans
et gagne 180 roubles par mois
il est marié il a une fille de six ans
et il habite un appartement
communautaire à leningrad volodia prend
le risque de nous emmener chez lui car
volodia est en colère
donc à regarder dans quelles conditions
on nous fait vivre le toit est percé
depuis cinq ans il ya de l'eau au
plafond des kills comme les relâcher
résigne a pas d'eau au robinet qui
changea déjà pas brillé je travaillais
j'ai même menacé de ne plus payer mon
loyer
il faut qu aux enchères fiche de paye en
est de plus en plus n'ont pas non plus
dans la salle de bain pas d'eau froide
nous explique paulo dias car de l'eau
chaude il n'y en a jamais eu
le chauffe eau n'a jamais marché depuis
des années on me renvoie de bureau en
bureau
j'ai écrit par peur mais
l'administration ne fait rien dans cet
appartement communautaire volodia
partage la cuisine la salle de bain et
les toilettes
il a droit à deux pièces une chambre où
il dort avec sa femme et sa fille et une
salle à manger les meubles lui
appartiennent la télévision lui vient de
son père ouvrier comme lui et militants
du parti depuis 50 ans il achète piedoie
crédit 35 roubles par mois
je m y avait de la musique
moi je n'ai pas pu - kpn belgique c'est
important ce terrain c'est le seul luxe
que vous avez finalement je m'en voulais
avec la voiture oui
volodia n'a pas le droit de recevoir des
étrangers chez lui et le ras-le-bol du
prolétaire rouge et plus de morts que la
peur volodia ne supporte plus la
condition qui lui est fait
c'est une véritable catastrophe que vit
le plus septentrional des états
américains l'alaska depuis vendredi
l'échouage d'un pétrolier a provoqué une
immense marée noire la plus grave de
l'histoire des états unis
les moyens de secours apparaissent
inadaptés et les autorités américaines
semblent impuissants pour lutter contre
ce désastre dominique verdeilhan onze
ans après la moco cadix les mêmes images
mais cette fois cela se passe en alaska
à 40 km du port de valdez le pétrolier
d'où s'est échappé depuis vendredi soir
près de 40 millions de litres de pétrole
à ses côtés désormais un autre pétrolier
de la même compagnie ils pompent des
soutes les deux cent mille barils de
pétrole toujours à bord du navire
accidenté plus de 6 kilomètres de
barrages flottants ont été établis afin
d'empêcher à la nappe de 260 kilomètres
carrés de superficie de s'étendre
davantage dans le détroit du prince
williams enfin les nuit dernière des
pompiers et procédé à des tentatives
d'évaporation par le feu des mesures que
le commandant cousteau juge inadaptée et
dérisoire face aux véritables
conséquences écologiques
en quoi ces gens c'est de répondre à la
surface quelques fois par un juge en
effet selon cissé mélangeant pétrole
s'écoule et enfin bravo
alors évidemment ça nettoie la surface
par saison du moins et tout vendu rayé
on a fait quelque chose
ce désastre a changé de place pour un
désastre pour la région de valdez qui
vit essentiellement de la pêche la marée
noire intervient la veille de la saison
de la pêche au hareng aux crustacés et
au saumon pour les pêcheurs quel que
soit le résultat de l'enquète les
dommages économiques sont considérables
et de longue durée sans pêche
il n'ya plus d'emploi ici à moins que ce
ne soit la compagnie exxon qui nous
nourrissent en alaska
on parle dédommagement comme en bretagne
il ya onze lenteur des opérations de
nettoyage faiblesse des moyens la
polémique se développe aux états unis
polémique aussi sur le trafic pétrolier
qui est de moins en moins sur polémique
enfin sur les responsabilités de la
compagnie exxon jacquat bouchard frankia
rossi l'un des responsables d'exxon a
couru en alaska a d'ores et déjà reconnu
la responsabilité de la compagnie dans
la catastrophe
on a confirmé qu'au moment de l'accident
c'est le troisième officiers du navire
qui dirigeait la manoeuvre en infraction
du règlement le commandant j'aurais
hazlewood qui aurais tu un problème
d'alcoolisme dans le passé se trouvait
dans sa cabine
leur représentante exxon a répété à
l'intention des pêcheurs et des
habitants touchés par la nappe de
pétrole qui seraient indemnisés pour
toutes les pertes subies du fait de la
marée noire
exane l'une des toutes premières
compagnies pétrolières aux états unis a
été incapable d'empêcher la
contamination des eaux en raison de ces
réaction tardive et inefficace estime le
gouverneur de l'alaska
le gouverneur a déclaré zone sinistrée
tout le périmètre de valdez ils
réclament l'intervention personnelle de
georges bush
qui est resté silencieux sur la
catastrophe jusqu'à présent voilà donc
ce que l'on disait aux etats-unis
aujourd'hui avec nous maintenant patrick
lagadec
vous êtes spécialiste de ce genre de
risque qui vous êtes chercheur à l'école
polytechnique sur ce domaine des risques
technologiques majeurs vous alliez vous
avez d'ailleurs écrit plusieurs ouvrages
à ce sujet lorsqu'il surprend tout de
suite c'est que les américains
paraissent bien impuissant par cette
catastrophe
je crois que ce type de catastrophes
comme d'autres chimique ou nucléaire
pose rapidement des problèmes
d'impossibilité et c'est pour ça qu'il
faut d'abord les prévenir
et c'est pour ça que j'ai introduit en
france ce concept de risques
technologiques majeurs montrant qu'il
faut prévenir les accidents et ensuite
savoir quand même les traités
j'entendais dans votre commentaire que
les américains n'étaient peut-être pas
tout à fait prêt pour faire face
immédiatement ce genre de problème et
pourtant ils sont sensibilisés peut-être
plus que nous à l'écologie oui
certainement ils ont fait beaucoup de
travail sur la question en france aussi
je crois que après la moco k10 on avait
pris quelques mesures du type repousser
les bateaux plus loin du large
prévoir les dispositifs de ce qu'on a
appelé des rails pour les conduire de
manière plus sûre de la manche est
également ce qu'on a fait d'intéressant
en france c'est de mettre en place un
centre de recherche mais qui aujourd'hui
les situe à brest qui aujourd'hui à
certains problèmes certains voudraient
peut-être se retirer je crois que
l'exemple montre qu'il faut continuer
absolument cette guerre de vigilance
ceaucescu technologiques majeures qui
sont très importants quelquefois
l'impression justement qu'au cours de
ces dernières années n'a pas eu
tellement de progrès dans la protection
de l'environnement et dans ce domaine du
transport pétrole et c'était les trois
points que je suis né tout de suite et
je soulignerai vraiment l'importance
d'investir sur le sujet et quand il ya
un centre de recherche qui marche comme
un vrai ce qui s'appelle le cèdre et
bien que les uns et les autres
continuent à financer ce projet qui doit
pouvoir vivre
et comme nous avons eu récemment un
problème de lin dan dans la manche il ya
ceux qui est un v6 valorise notre bateau
un autre produit qui n'est pas du
pétrole mais de la chimie et bien si les
pétroliers investissent dans un centre
de recherche comme celui du salembre sb
que le chimiste fassent de même pour
qu'on ne ratera pas seulement les katas
sur une fois qu'elles se sont produites
alors les occidentaux c'est vrai
apparaissent maintenant les français
aussi en particulier beaucoup plus
sensibles à l'écologie quelles
initiatives il faudrait prendre encore
je crois qu'il va falloir peut-être
réart réorienter les grands arbitrages
et des grandes compagnies qui ont été
sujettes des accidents ou des alertes
c'est inquiétant ont par exemple pris en
compte le fait que l'environnement
devrait être traitée dorénavant eau à la
direction de l'entreprise au niveau du
président qui doit prendre en charge ce
problème directement pour que les
arbitrages sont bien faits dans ce
domaine est également son doux pour que
l'information soit bien celle pour que
la vigilance des autorités des
responsables productif ne se ne s'allège
pas bien que des institutions nouvelles
soient créées pour alerter les uns et
les autres s'il ya insuffisance
manifeste ou insuffisances vu dans le
domaine c'est par exemple en france le
collège de risques majeurs institutions
nouvelles indépendant d'experts qui
doivent dire attention attention il
s'agit de risque majeur prenons bien nos
responsabilités merci patrick lagadec
fin de la trêve pascale en corse dès ce
soir la grève générale du secteur public
entre dans sa sixième semaine et elle
pourrait s'accompagner de la reprise du
blocus ce soir les syndicats du nord
comme du sud de la corse sont réunis ils
appellent à de nouvelles manifestations
françoise joly quand le sud rencontre le
nord cela fait du monde
et à défaut de pouvoir pousser les murs
en improvisent une salle de réunion dans
un couloir celui du local de force
ouvrière une rencontre programmée à ses
heures mais qui a débuté à 17 heures
avec l'arrivée tardive de la cgt la cgt
qui elle demande toujours la prime
d'insularité alors que les autres
syndicats parlent de mesures
compensatoires contre la vie chère
aucun problème les problèmes techniques
nous devions nous arrêter à l'union
départementale le temps de regrouper
tous nos militants c'est un retard qui
n'a rien de politique
réunis depuis plus de trois heures les
sept organisations syndicales tentent de
mettre au point des actions communes sur
le plan régional mais pour l'instant
seule décision concrète déjà connu les
manifestations de mercredi
dans chaque ville le stc le syndicat des
travailleurs corses proche du mouvement
nationaliste n'y participera pas il
défilera de son côté mais pas avant cinq
jours samedi prochain demain matin les
assemblées générales se tiendront dans
toutes les administrations
ce sont elles qui donneront le ton de la
mobilisation et salariés de la fonction
publique entament leur sixième semaine
de grève
ils savent plus que jamais que le
gouvernement est décidé à jouer la
fermeté seul négociations prévues avec
les pouvoirs publics maintenant les
tables rondes de michel rocard mais
normalement pas avant la fin de la
semaine
deux informations encore à propos de la
corse d'abord ce soir à l'hôtel matignon
semble plutôt attendre pas de nouveau
les services du premier ministre
semblent vouloir pour l'instant laissé
la situation se décanter et puis
deuxième information cette déclaration
il y à quelques minutes du porte parole
de l'intersyndicale corse écouter ce
qu'elle disait si le gouvernement prend
la responsabilité de ne pas satisfaire
les salariés en lutte dans les plus
brefs délais il faut qu'ils sachent que
s'organise dès à présent une marche sur
paris
tous ensemble nous laverons l'affront et
nous gagnerons une semaine difficile
pour lionel jospin les syndicats
vraisemblablement ne signerons pas
l'accord que souhaite le ministre de
l'éducation pourtant monsieur jospin a
fait plusieurs propositions la semaine
dernière il valait confirmer demain
annonçant une rallonge de budget pour la
revalorisation des enseignements une
explosion cet après midi dans un vieux
quartier de vincennes vers 16h un
immeuble de quatre étages près de
l'église a été soufflée par une
explosion vraisemblablement à cause
d'une fuite de gaz
li a huit blessés dont trois sont
grièvement atteints
l'immeuble a bien sûr été évacués car on
craint maintenant qu'il ne s'effondre
et puis un nouvel incident très grave
des skinheads qui se sont attaqués cette
fois à les nomades
cela s'est passé dans le cher à mareuil
sur arnon il ya eu un blessé grave n'est
pas la première fois que ces skin heads
font parler d'eux il déteste les
étrangers ils le disent il aime surtout
se battre et leur violence a déjà fait
des victimes agnès poirier et christian
hottin ont voulu savoir ce qu'ils
étaient vraiment les skinheads dans la
région de toulouse ils en ont rencontré
quelques-uns des peintres les cuisiniers
des déménageurs qui ont choisi cette
violence et qui sont donc les skinheads
reporte à l'électrique moi j'ai le
national socialisme et j'en suis fier ça
va être un beau josh hill suffisent de
prolétaires mon grand père est quant à
elle cinq mille pattes et mon grand père
est communiste
moi je sus national socialiste ça crée
un très grand choc dans ma famille j'en
ai rien à [ __ ]
des mots dont on se gargarise l'uniforme
nous ont trahis crâne rasé chaussures
doc marteens leur tient lieu de pensée
politique et skin heads de toulouse sont
une trentaine tous différents
contradictoires indisciplinés c'est la
haine de l'étranger qui les rassemble
pas question de militer aucun parti ne
trouve grâce à leurs yeux
pas même le front national certaines
certaines chapelles opposition centriste
mais je ne suis pas d'accord pour leurs
trente ans il ya une nouvelle nouveaux
mouvements de jeunesse étrangères qui
arrivent
ce sont des feignants alors qu'il ya
plein de petits jeunes français qui sont
dehors en tant attendu boulot qui galère
qui aime répondre bien me prendre la
place de ces feignants de d'étrangers
qui sont la halle à leur place
la violence des mots la violence des
sons leur musique c'est la houille
musique tempo rapide parole extrême
toujours plus d'ordre toujours moins
d'étrangers
en
ce soir concert rock à toulouse la
fouille minutieuse
on les laissera rentrée s'il ne porte
pas d'un signe mais les insignes canton
et skins se porte à même la peau
il en a tous âges parle de nostalgie
d'orange mécanique et du troisième reich
apparu en angleterre il ya vingt ans en
réaction au mouvement hippie et skins
est lent finissent pas de renaître
ou bien être conscient d'un truc c'est
que la violence fascine et bon c'est
vrai que ça fascine c'est bien quand
être comptés dans le métro on crame
rasés en coupant en treillis en paraboot
c'est là un jour en faisant goût tu as
les gens ont peur tu te sens quelque
chose sud sans exister pas oublier qu'il
ya aussi quand tu regardes le monde
autour de nous les gens ne savent plus
où situez il est clair que les jeunes
qui ne savent pas où est situé devant
les terrains là ils sentent en position
de force
jusqu'au jour où l'uniforme skins est
trop lourd à porter quand la bande est
indésirable partout en ville
sauf dans ses derniers bastions quand
pour beaucoup ce qui n'aide devient
synonyme de voyous alors on raccroche
comme bisounours skinheads depuis l'âge
de 14 ans avant ça me faisait plaisir de
frapper sur un immigré tournant africain
maintenant ça fait plaisir c'est tout
est-ce que ça n'aboutit à rien
oussama si ça marche avoir que des
problèmes comme je répète avec la
justice des déboires et ses tons moi
j'ai envie de prendre un loyer à voir
une femme des enfants travailler à la
fois salle jean bissonnette bientôt
ranger calme et peut-être mais leur
haine leur obsession d'une france
blanche leur idéal restera travail
famille patrie le liban toujours dans la
tourmente les habitants de beyrouth sont
resté retranché toute la journée d'hier
jour de pâques
assailli par de terribles tirs
d'artillerie à tout à l'heure à paris
les libanais de france manifesté devant
l'ambassade de syrie en france plusieurs
centaines de libanais qui voulait
protester contre le fils oh nage de
beyrouth par l'armée syrienne
ce lundi à beyrouth une accalmie n'est
les combats entre chrétiens libanais
forces syriennes se sont poursuivies
cette fois dans les hauteurs de la
capitale libanaise bilan trois morts 13
blessés parmi la population civile
pierre serra le cycle quotidien des
bombardements a pris en quinze jours un
rythme de tradition la nuit en bambara
repos relatif le matin et on recommence
vers 17 heures l'artillerie pro-syrienne
attaque maintenant non seulement les
quartiers surpeuplés
mais aussi des objectifs vitaux
économique comme le confirme général
aoun que nous avons joué tout à l'heure
par téléphone et centrales électriques
vous allez obtenir combien de temps
c'est en tout cas l'avenir d'un pays qui
se joue en ce moment et aussi l'avenir
de ses enfants déjà marqué par ces
affrontements aveugle d'autant plus
violent qui sont dit-on fratricide
en espagne le thé à prolonge sa trêve
jusqu'au 24 juin prochain l'organisation
indépendantiste basque l'a annoncé tout
à l'heure alors que des contacts ont
lieu en ce moment même à alger entre le
gouvernement espagnol et les
représentants de l' eta
voyons tout de suite d'autres
informations internationales avec éric
perrin 400 à 600 otages aux mains des
mutins du pénitencier de pavone la
prison la plus importante du guatemala
les 1300 détenus se sont révoltés dans
la même ville hier alors que de nombreux
visiteurs se trouvaient à l'intérieur
ils réclament des réductions de peine et
d amélioration des conditions de
détention
les affrontements auraient fait au moins
six morts et 20 blessés les négociations
avec la direction sont actuellement
suspendus
cinglant revers du premier ministre turc
turgut ozal aux élections municipales et
provinciales son parti n'obtient la
majorité que dans 3 des 67 capitale de
province et de partis d'opposition sont
les grands gagnants de cette
consultation
en dépit de ce désaveu monsieur turgut
ozal a déclaré qu'il resterait au
pouvoir comme prévu jusqu'en 1992
les manifestants les forces anti-émeutes
ont fait usage de leurs armes dans la
province autonome yougoslave du kosovo
plusieurs dizaines de blessés et au
moins trois morts dont le commandant de
la police de pouzauges et vaud les
albanais majoritaires dans cette
province à 90% protestent contre la
reprise du contrôle du kosovo par la
serbie lors république de tutelle les
autorités yougoslave intensifie l'envoi
de forces blindées pour briser cette
montée en force du nationalisme albanais
et j'ajoute encore cette information
deux français disparus au sahara depuis
plus d'un mois maintenant on l'a appris
seulement aujourd'hui
il s'agit d'un marseillais d'un habitant
du var âgés tous deux de moins de 30 ans
ils ont disparu dans le sud algérien
il aurait été surpris par une tempête de
sable leurs proches demandent que les
recherches
abandonné par l'état algérien soit
maintenant reprise et en automobile
les italiennes sur tous les fronts
ferrari gagné hier le grand prix de rio
en formule 1 ces lentilles acquis
aujourd'hui remporte le safari rally
c'est une classique des rallyes qui
compte pour le championnat du monde et
qui a lieu au kenya
victoire donc d'une italienne lancia
conduite par anne italien viazzo thierry
blancot biasio reste décidément le
spécialiste de toutes les surfaces
champion du monde en titre le pilote
italien a remporté jusqu'aujourd'hui les
trois épreuves comptant pour le
championnat du monde des rallye
monte-carlo portugal et safari
son principal adversaire l'argentin
djardji récalde est sûre l'ancien a dû
abandonner hier après avoir heurté un
troupeau de moutons alors qu'ils étaient
en tête depuis le début
second comme l'an dernier le kenyan mike
carland à 1h20 des lancia mais avec la
première japonaise classe et une nissan
dans le clan des deux roues motrices
belle performance pour le suédois stig
blomqvist troisième à deux heures de la
lancia sa mécanique a bien résisté au
piège de l'afrique
troisième victoire consécutive de la
saison
bia dionne et l'ancien en tête du
championnat du monde des rallyes pilotes
et marque en voit mal qui pourra mettre
en doute la suprématie italienne on ne
pourra plus dire de l'humanité que c'est
un grand quotidien parisien l'huma
change de façade et à défaut de changer
son look lubat s'installe à saint denis
rue jean jaurès l'honneur est sauf
stéphane magnier camarades
on est prié de vider les casiers et les
lieux vendredi soir le rédacteur en chef
n'avait pas encore opéré mais le
directeur lui montrait l'exemple que
l'organe du parti communiste quitte
paris et la rue du faubourg poissonnière
cela veut dire que l'uma doit à son tour
accepter la dure loi économique une
baisse des ventes parallèles à la perte
d'influencé du parti cent dix mille
exemplaires aujourd'hui malgré la
distribution faite par des militants
le journal perdait de l'argent alors
comment at il pu se faire construire au
pied de la basilique saint denis ce
superbe bâtiment de 60 millions de
francs signé oscar niemeyer l'architecte
de brasilia avec informatisation de la
rédaction et de la photocomposition
cette dépense est couverte par la vente
d'une partie de nos locaux de la rue du
faubourg poissonnière seconde mans par
la réduction des coûts de fabrication et
troisièmement par le soutien de nos
lecteurs nous lançons une grande
souscription à l'automne
merci les militants phrase clé alluma on
reverse le tiers de son salaire au
journal le revenu moyen est de 8800
francs par mois et tout ça nos vies à 90
% de la vente du journal
il nous a fallu remonter à la page 26 du
22 mars dernier pour trouver une
publicité commerciale alors la
municipalité communiste de saint denis a
trouvé une petite place pour les
camarades dandy
difficulté quand on n'a pas de pub il
faut des fidèles la technologie la plus
moderne au service de l'art le plus
ancien c'est le nucléaire qui se met au
service des musées de france
l'appareil cet agrès un accélérateur de
particules il est unique au monde
il va permettre d'étudier et
d'authentifier les oeuvres d'art il sera
inauguré jeudi soir au louvre patrick
estève contraste saisissant une toile de
1750 signé par le peintre beau mieux
exposés aux faisceaux de particules d'un
accélérateur ultra moderne baptisé hague
l'aïe
nous sommes dans les sous sols du
laboratoire des musées de france
avec cette machine unique au monde le
musée du louvre se place à l'avant garde
de la recherche exposés aux
bombardements de protons la toile
réfléchie des rayons qui sont captés
puis analysées par ordinateur les divers
constituants apparaissent distinctement
sur l'écran du centre de contrôle
il devient ainsi possible de percer les
secrets des mélange de pigments utilisés
par les artistes et même de dater les
hommes avec précision le cas des
primitifs italiens par le temps on va
essayer de retrouver à quelle date le
tableau a été réalisé en étudiant le
pigment jaune et par la présence ou
l'absence de silicium on va pouvoir dire
si un objet a été peint avant 440 ou
après cette date
infaillible pour détecter les vrais des
faux tableaux
cet accélérateur de particules va
également améliorer nos connaissances
historiques par exemple aglaé permet de
connaître l'âge de cette roche de dater
la gravure comme étant de l'époque
magdalénienne treize mille ans mais
aussi d'affirmer que les pattes arrière
de l'animal ont été gravés il ya
seulement deux mille ans après les
musées le théâtre nouveau coup d'éclat
pour le groupe c'est chaque fois que ces
argentins présente un spectacle c'est
toujours un événement depuis le célèbre
succès des peines de coeur d'une chatte
anglaise cette fois ça se passe à
aubervilliers c'est au théâtre de la
commune la pièce s'appelle famille
d'artistes c'est une famille drôle
émouvante qui vit hors du temps georges
bégoux yves dreux reportage
dans une maison délabrée du vieux buenos
aires est vite une extravagante famille
d'émigrés italiens tous des artistes ils
en ont en tout cas l'âme et la folie
ida se prend pour une étoile de l'opéra
elle attend un imprésario qui comme
godot ne viendra pas autre chose
le seul homme si l'on peut dire se croit
vedette à l'alcazar
quant à la mama elle a de gros soucis on
veut raser la maison pour cause d'
autoroutes
cette famille ont dû commun pour
laquelle tout est prétexte à jeu a
réellement existé et son livre d'or
contenait les signatures des noms les
plus illustres qui la visitaient comme
une curiosité locale nous elle
correspond à vos des souvenirs d'enfance
a déçu rennais adolescence que j'ai eu
du théâtre et de la vie des buenos aires
c'est à dire qu'il y à tout ce mélange
des genres des théâtres que je veux ce
mélodrame lci net et comme on appelle là
que c'était un théâtre populaire qui
s'est fait céder les face au public avec
une énorme émotion et en même temps une
sorte de tendresse dont les maires
voulait conquérir
l âme auxerre 17 familles et
l'atmosphère d'une folle idée que je
crois que tu une folie qui nous
appartient et l'argentine
poursuivant le rêve jusqu'au bout
eduardo arias termine en compte de fait
cette histoire surréaliste sur une fort
belle musique d'astor piazzolla
plus prosaïque les résultats du tiercé
cet état evry cet après-midi alors voici
l'ordre d'arrivée 8,19 11025 francs dans
l'ordre 205 francs dans le désordre il y
avait aussi un quarté + à evry c'est la
même chose avec un cheval de plus 8 19
11 15 3534 francs dans l'ordre 4320
francs dans le désordre
puis le trio ses 58 20 tout ça fait pour
6 francs pour la fin de ce journal tout
de suite la météo avec laurent cabrol
qui vous donnera aussi des nouvelles des
encombrements sur la route qui on est et
qui sont encore très importants un peu
avant minuit ce sera henri sannier pour
la dernière édition du journal et puis
demain comme d'habitude marque hautement
catherine ceylac roger zabel pour
télématin à demain soir 20h